[Music]
gratulations where is the ring oh we
have to hide it for a little bit it's
not here as of right now okay but
they'll make it when she first took it
off yes
was it just the most amazing experience
I mean did you see it coming did you
know what's gonna happen we can't really
elaborate on the engagement right now
but we're definitely engaged with me
you're very happy we're in love this
stuff can you tease if there were maybe
any tears source there were tears I
think we can say that that's kind of a
dead giveaway Nick told me that he would
love to officiate your guys's wedding do
you have a response to that we do but we
don't bachelor family family we have
somebody in mind this very year
[Music]
we have talked more about that
everything has just been happening so
fast the announced it just came we just
got engaged so I think we're just
soaking that in right now and really
enjoying our time together and the fact
that we're engaged we're fiancees we're
obviously now hoping for a televised
wedding what can you tell me about that
as are there discussions involved there
some minuscule amount of discussion but
now no we just got engaged what is the
biggest change in the relationships
since the engagement I mean it's been a
couple of days have you noticed anything
is it weird to call each other fiance
the fact that we get to call each other
fiance is probably the biggest
difference there hasn't been a
difference in our relationship which is
pretty cool but you know I just fall in
love with her more and more every day
are you guys living together yet is that
going to happen no a couple months from
now I just moved into a new place so
it's still getting settled in he needs
to bring his dog over here and then like
in the winter late fall will start
mending all that together are you in
wedding planning mode oh no no I mean
like we have a timeline but that's but
you know it's been three days our head
says 2019 you have three wedding must
have three wedding must-haves well we
don't want it's like a limit on our
guest list
we definitely want you wanna I think we
want a bigger way yeah and we agree on
that
we pretty much agree on where we would
lose want it and with Jays and then I
definitely am preset on a princess dress
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]